[Music]
this morning our spring into summer
series is celebrating the reopening of
museums and memorials
many popular sites are open again with
new coveted safety measures in place
so starting today that includes a place
with one of the best views of the
nation's capital
visitors can return to arlington house
the general robert e lee memorial
an extensive overhaul by the national
park service brought together
descendants
of both general lee and enslaved people
who once lived and
labored on his estate only on cbs this
morning jericho duncan there she is
was there when they met up in person for
the very first time jericho good to see
you in the studio what was it like
always good to see you too it was
incredible it was a remarkable moment
nearly 200 years in the making
now the families have found common
ground all hoping
to tell a more complete story of a place
with a very complicated history
the crown that sits atop the hallowed
ground of arlington national cemetery
is this mansion it has a commanding view
of our nation's capital
and was once home to general robert e
lee
but to get here required taking many
steps forward
on the left that's robert e lee the
fifth walking for the first time
with descendants of others who also once
lived here
the enslaved when you come here how do
you feel
i get a connection i think about the
people who actually
helped to build it inez parks and steve
hammond have roots at this historic site
inez's great grandfather james parks dug
the first graves at arlington
there's a people of deserving people
they need their stories told in new
exhibits opening today
the lives of parks and those who labored
for free
are now a greater focus at this national
memorial
the park service restored these former
slave quarters that had become the
site's bookstore
the fact that we have chosen to change
it back into a place of honor
i think is a very big deal aaron larocca
is with the national park service
could you have imagined a day like this
15 years ago when you first started
no we've really been able to progress to
uplift the story of all the people here
a story steve hammond and his family
have spent years unraveling
robert e lee ultimately signs a deed to
free
40 people that were enslaved here and
charles syphax
is one of those hammond learned that
general lee freed his relative charles
syfax
and dozens of other enslaved people the
stories are very complex
and they're i think worth the country
knowing more about rob lee and his
sister tracy lee crittenberger
agree they're the general's great great
grandchildren
you are robert e lee the fifth and i
have a feeling you might have a son
i think you're right with the same name
while the family has kept the name alive
they've worked to bury the ideals
associated with it
after seeing the images from
charlottesville in 2017
last summer's global reckoning on racial
injustice
and watching statues of general lee come
down
his family spoke up what was that
conversation like within your family
i think it was really all those things
need to happen
as a lee family we stand completely in
alignment with the social justices that
are going on today
there's no chance that we're going to be
the leaders of this
but if we can do one small thing here is
just to say we want to move
forward so does billionaire
philanthropist david rubenstein
he donated more than 12 million dollars
toward the national park services
restoration project
and wants to remove robert e lee's name
why
fight so hard to make that change well i
think that
robert e lee is a person who symbolizes
some people things that probably are not
appropriate but renaming the memorial
would take an act of congress
drop the robert e lee name from it but
it doesn't expunge
his history here it's not just about
general lee
it's about all the families that lived
here and all their voices
the women's voices the children's voices
generations later families connected by
a painful past
freed the untold stories to honor the
people who made this
a national treasure i get emotional
talking about it
it's a very powerful opportunity to
bring
people together and try to make a
difference in a better world
is it fair to say that you dreamed of
this moment absolutely
i have been looking forward to this for
years
well the park service site as we
mentioned reopens today and those
conversations between the families as
you can imagine
continue at the end of the day details
matter
yes and knowing your history matters but
more importantly they were able to tell
the stories of people who had a great
contribution there that really weren't
told in this way before
facts matter even when the facts are
very uncomfortable it's very interesting
to see the lee family though robert e
lee the fifth saying
we believe it's time i love that they
took the bookstore and restored it to
the slave quarter so people could
see the structure that was there and how
they lived exactly very powerful piece
eureka thank you